you are looking at the skyline of
Chicago the city where the notorious
gangsta John Dillinger was killed back
in 1934 he was known as public enemy
number one during the height of the
Great Depression and after his death
there were many conspiracy theories
surrounding his fate now his family is
moving forward with plans to exhume his
body and Dean Reynolds is gonna tell us
all about it Dean good morning well John
Dillinger was shot right outside this
theater 85 years ago this month but
fascination with the gangster has never
really died and now a relative has
granted permission to have his body
exhumed rekindling interest all over
again
played here by Johnny Depp in the movie
Public Enemies John Dillinger was a
1930s antihero over now a serial bank
robber during the Great Depression he
was a ruthless self-assured even
charming hoodlum with a knack for
eluding cops and escaping jail
Dillinger's believed to have been
involved in dozens of midwest bank heist
making off with around three hundred
thousand dollars the equivalent of four
million today a police officer was
killed in one of the robberies leading
Dillinger to be considered public enemy
number one
but it all came to a halt when federal
and local law enforcement tracked him to
a theater in Chicago and gunned him down
on the sidewalk outside a month after
his 31st birthday
Dillinger's infamy drew thousands of
curious spectators who wanted to look at
his body before it was buried here in
section 44 of the crown Hill Cemetery in
Indianapolis it's an interesting story
and it just keeps keeps him during
spiros bite Estados runs an organization
that owns the largest collection of
Dillinger artifacts he's been dead for
85 years why is their enduring interest
in this guy he created this image of
Robin Hood that people during the Great
Depression bought into in death
Dillinger became the focus of books more
than one Museum and of course movies but
with that also came conspiracy theories
about whether he was really even dead
theories his descendants may be trying
to clarify CBS News obtained this permit
that gives Dillinger's nephew permission
to have his body exhumed and then
reburied on September 16th the permit
does not give a reason but the History
Channel told us it's related to a
documentary by tostado thinks there's
really no mystery to this history
Americans have a fascination with with
odd stories and with conspiracy theories
and you know wanting to keep legends and
myths alive I think he got gunned down I
think we're gonna find that it's him
laying under two tons of concrete at
Crown Hill Cemetery spoiler alert by the
way for everybody watching at home now
what the History Channel hopes to learn
from all of this is unclear
and the relative of Dillinger isn't
talking but John Dillinger's legend
clearly lives on Tony I think what the
History Channel hopes to learn is how
many people will tune in thank you the
only mystery yeah eighty years later